[Music]
honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
center pieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg we ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fault someone just left it in the
bathroom
[Music]
he forgot to put his shirt all the way
out
time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left food is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice
won't work why so many steps
look at once
not once did I wonder
if I'd be walking Hancock
Through the Jungle with a live grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
we're gonna fix this
and just growing on me I wanted
something less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Music]
your sister
Carol thank you for the cake knife
[Music]